hi bros before this video begins I have
something to tell you I'm going to be
live-streaming this game with you bros
today so check out speedrunners and
check out my livestream at twitch.tv
slash pewdiepie i'm gonna stream at 4
p.m. PST all the info you need to know
is in the description enjoy the video
yourself in yeah i'm just clicking on
you should be Sam hey your baby bear
wait why are you the scout uh ok wait
are you ready yeah are you ready I'm
feel like I'm hyping this up too much ha
ha ha
BAM oh hey Lucius leggy so whoever loses
gets to tweet is that they get they make
what the other person tweet something
gay you weight worth it can you hear my
character I can hear ya girl my that's
my amazing voice acting really yes
you actually voice acted oh I forgot a
blender for a second Jesus you doing oh
damn that speak how do you do that ah
yeah ah yes oh yeah here's what I'm
cracking about yeah get it I said I get
it nobody cares you're joking
oh did I just pass you up I thought I
had a grappling hook
bollocks bollocks I don't have a grapple
of my eyes upset when he says bollocks
Oh Brad is joining okay good at least
then I can beat him or something a nice
he written it at this game he's never
played it so yes I only played this game
against people who are not as good as me
wait wait wait up wait up I'm ahead of
you're ahead of I think I have a taunt
move as well I need to show you it to do
it [ __ ] no no wait come here anyway
my dear wait honey uh playing with
controller oh nice hi like that [ __ ]
don't hold on Jack Elma I almost called
you PewDiePie Adam [ __ ] that what's
wrong do you wanna build a snowman
yeah I win yeah my game frozen so how do
I play this game we had a we had our
deal that if you if you lose you have to
everyone gets to tell the others what to
tweet oh my god
and I just won I didn't [ __ ] agree to
that you did you sign it you now all
right I guess we can start now because
you technically crashed yeah but I
thought I don't know what I'm doing okay
we're going no I don't know how to play
the game let's play silo look at my
chariot yeah just in a [ __ ] menu
no you're in the game you liar
have you lie yeah son of a [ __ ] me out
you piece of [ __ ] ronster
[ __ ] don't concern yourself over [ __ ]
you [ __ ] murder you
oh my god yes
hey don't catch up with me
oh yeah oh gee
no no no what
I don't know this level crap yeah well I
barely know any of them so what the [ __ ]
is this ah what the [ __ ] was I you were
like we have too many followers let's
find someone with significantly
followers who it won't matter where they
just tweet out like suck my dick oh yeah
let's go oh wait this game oh whoa hey
you come back here [ __ ] ha ha
fell for that old trick didn't ya oh
this chick in the bird Wow well weed for
the brand
they're all just stacking I did it they
did it it it I lose again
yeah I don't even know if I've lost
that's how much I don't know how to play
this game
hey wow wow yeah
oh my god I'm back in the game walk walk
I don't know how to even [ __ ] Club I
paid 7 pound for you to just [ __ ] on me
and then night you say a shitty tweet
yeah that's bad speech too that's what
is it so I get a couple of sick twisted
[ __ ] no no no no yeah oh you
want me to send a tweet ok tweet this
what's he tweeting a [ __ ] hate when
people have bad grammar that's what you
made him tweet yeah it's it's subtle
really cuz grammar was misspelled Oh
Plus everyone on Twitter be like oh you
don't know Bambi hey what is Ken get to
be topless [ __ ] please that's not Ken's
Ches alright I've seen that thing and
it's hairier than a chimpanzee oh my god
I mean there's a guy throws a chumpy PM
I'm still in how do you do that
yeah hey you can't play that game
bastard face and bastard face you're a
real bastard RJ don't buy your little
life for a sneaky son of a pooper desk
Oh what am i doing over here what the
[ __ ]
don't [ __ ] up alright alright guys I'm
back oh he's rad playing in the video
guys know why I'm in idea don't you dare
grapple me I swear video he went to MIDI
oh hey don't do it don't don't do it
don't be that guy nobody likes that guy
Ken no way to be e what sir I've won two
every time then you've come back right
at the end I don't know why I am in this
video why am I here for what did you
think was gonna happen fast
you're right like I'm a sexy wittle baby
oh I'm a sexy wittle baby
look at that [ __ ] spider-man
[ __ ] I can get over here imma
gonna actually survive though it's the
[ __ ] am i exit stage whenever I go I'm
rocking mother father what was happening
right now what are you doing Brad just
to run I don't know what that means you
know I don't know hahaha go Brad use
your use your powers I don't know how to
do that tonight oh yeah rock it away I
just press the nearest button no why are
you so [ __ ] fast on the sudden yeah I
killed that that is what is oh oh I like
this
how did I lose [ __ ] you feel it Oh what
I have to do is win this now and Phoenix
has to tweet something right you should
let me win like the other option for me
yeah yeah not that bad it's kind of in
line with what you'd write anyway
[ __ ] sake I'm not gonna tweet that
yeah sweet up wait that this is UT wait
that it's not that fast it's gonna come
on man
grow a pair and tweet it [ __ ]
q
Oh